Україна збирається створити власну систему протиракетної оборони і для отримання необхідних для цього технологій
вже почала переговори з іншими країнами. Про це заявив міністр закордонних справ України Дмитро Кулеба.
Саме протиракетна і протиповітряна оборона - нині найбільш проблемні місця в українській системі безпеки.
За словами опитаних DW експертів, створити українську ПРО швидко не вдасться.
Не менше 7 років піде на таку розробку, виходячи з того, що це система, це комплекс засобів.
У нас є дуже суттєві напрацювання щодо ракет, у нас є на світовому рівні розробки радарних систем.
Але система наведення, система перешкодозахищеності - тут у нас просто немає такої практики і це треба все напрацьовувати.
Щодо протиповітряної системи загалом, то Україна має комплекси С-300 - для прикриття важливих об'єктів.
Прикриття військ забезпечують системи малої і середньої дальності - від ЗРК "Бук" до "Оси", а також переносні зенітно-ракетні комплекси.
Українська система ППО фактично не оновлювалася ще від часів здобуття незалежності, хоча багато що вдалося модернізувати.
За оцінками експертів, більшість комплексів мають кінцевий термін експлуатації - максимум до 2030 року.
На практиці ж зняття з озброєння через вичерпання ресурсу почнеться за лічені роки.
Замінити їх можна власними модернізованими розробками. Можна спробувати інтегрувати й іноземні зразки.
Щодо засобів малої дальності, це ізраїльський "Залізний купол". А також системи, які є в Швейцарії.
А щодо засобів середньої дальності, то я не знаю кращих систем, ніж С-300 і "Буки".
Якщо наша промисловість навчилася модернізувати ці системи, то вони на довгі роки будуть ще актуальними за своїми технічними характеристиками.
Їх і за дальністю вистачає, і вони мають гарну перешкодозахищеність. Я сам працював і знаю, що це таке.
Водночас Київ виступає за розгортання в Україні сил протиповітряної оборони за участі американських підрозділів.
За словами віцепрем'єра Олексія Резнікова, українське законодавство це дозволяє,
просто не треба це називати "військовими базами", а проводити співпрацю з точки зору навчання і тренування.
У США зацікавленість Києва у поглибленні співпраці з американцями для створення українського протиповітряного щита поки не коментували.
Експерти пояснюють, у чому полягають головні складнощі.
Таке можливо. Це перекрило б ті дірки, які існують в системі ППО України.
Але, знову ж таки, постає питання про взаємодію і сумісність цих засобів із уже існуючою в Україні системою. Це досить складно.
Я не думаю, що Сполучені Штати і Україна підуть на те, щоб розгортати тут висотну протиракетну систему THAAD.
Це відразу спричинить невдоволення з боку Росії - не з точки зору країни-агресора, а з точки зору країни,
яка бере участь у переговорах з питань обмеження озброєнь.
А для них система ПРО - як червона ганчірка для бика.
Натомість інший елемент протиракетної оборони США, а саме зенітно-ракетні комплекси Patriot, теоретично можуть бути застосовані в Україні.
Вони перебувають на озброєнні, зокрема у Німеччині, Греції, Іспанії, а також у деяких країнах Близького Сходу та Азії.
Через проблеми сумісності ЗРК Patriot не можуть швидко влитися в наявну українську систему ППО. На це можуть піти роки.
А без належної інтеграції не буде очікуваного ефекту. Приміром, до Польщі перші системи Patriot мають надійти на озброєння лише наступного року,
хоча контракт підписали ще 2018-го. Це також дуже дорого.
Наступного року до Румунії доставлять ще три комплекси Patriot. Сума угоди - майже 4 мільярди доларів.
Це приблизно весь оборонний бюджет України на цей рік.
Крім того, існує проблема підготовки персоналу. Це не просто машина з ракетою, а цілий комплекс, керувати яким ще потрібно навчитися.
Для порівняння: підготовка до служби на патрульних катерах "Айленд", про передачу яких Україна і США домовилися ще три роки тому, досі триває.
Черговий український екіпаж на днях прибув до Балтимора.
А система ППО, за словами експертів, у понад 100 разів складніша за такі катери.